Okay, I am so in on this new for be movement.
Let's do it! You didn't know?
It's basically this movement for women on the left,
the feminist, who are upset and sick of men,
especially after this election.
So they are vowing to punish these men by refusing to date them,
to sleep with them, to marry them and to have children with them,
effectively taking themselves out of the gene pool.
They believe that these types of men do not respect them
and so they don't wanna have anything to do with them. Again,
I support this movement wholeheartedly,
cause these women are the types of women who are having abortions.
There roughly 600,000 abortions performed every year in this country
for purely elective reasons.
It's those women who are getting them.
So by all means, yes,
please stop sleeping with men.
These types of women are also always complaining
about how we are overpopulated, right?
They claim that there are too many people on the planet
and that we need to stop having children.
So if they really stick to their promise,
they will not be repopulating the earth
and everybody else will. They don't have to work out perfectly.
It would also save these men a lot of hardship and trouble
being with these types of women.
Not to mention the fact that millions
and millions and millions of women also voted for Donald Trump.
So it's not like the men will have nobody to choose.
From if we all really supported this movement,
it could almost abolished abortion.
Please everybody go check out the 4B movement.
And if you are a leftist feminist woman,
please join. I support you.
I will cheer you on in your endeavors.